Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie new X-Men Legion
footage X-Men Breaking Bad for the most powerful
mutant in the universe.
And new Logan trailer that's coming that I'll
explain, there will be a weekly giveaway just
like the Deadpool giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's a $20
Amazon gift card, I'll announce winners at
the end of this, so be sure to click that
bell to enable alerts so you don't miss anything.
So in case you have no idea what's going on
Legion is a new FX TV show based on the X-Men
universe of characters the most powerful mutant
in existence, not counting the Phoenix force
technically the Phoenix force is a cosmic
entity.
So number 10.
This is based on the Legion character David
Haller is the son of Professor X character
named Gabriel Holler who you might not be
familiar with, but in the comics she was just
somebody that Professor X rescued from being
catatonic using his abilities.
They fell in love had a child the way their
pitching the show is that it's sort of like
X-Men Breaking Bad and Westworld for the most
powerful mutant character is only eight episode,
so is kind of like a mini series it's all
about the dawn of his abilities him learning
about mutants the fact that he is a mutant
what his powers are, so number nine in the
comics he actually debuted as a villain in
the new mutants comic book remember that's
the comic book the Deadpool and cable both
debuted in that is typically presented is
an antihero because he's so powerful it drives
him insane because his powers sort of flow
from Professor X is sort of like an evolution
of that in the way that Jean great can't fully
control the Phoenix force, so he has all these
different personalities in each one of them
is capable of manifesting a different mutant
ability, so he has all these abilities inside
of them almost limitless potential that he
can only use one of them at a time depending
on which personality it is and sometimes their
evil personalities.
Sometimes there nice personalities so is the
kind of person that Wolverine wouldn't even
try to touch just like you are way too crazy
for me.
So that's why you see this set in and around
a mental institution.
So think of it is like Breaking Bad he's a
normal person who, to try to deal with the
mental illness then he discovers why he's
having all these crazy visions is because
of his abilities so the love interest that
you been seeing of the trailers this woman
here that he runs into is a woman named Sid
who also seems to have the ability to swap
consciousness with people later they fall
in love and he finds out that she was taken
by a group of people, so you see Melanie here
played by Jean smart.
I like the white it makes you think of Emma
Frost because this is set in the 70s you're
thinking about first-class arrow soothing
about first-class characters like the hellfire
club.
She's one of the therapists inside this mental
institution he has a sister that he cares
about was trying to help him on the outside
most you're probably familiar with Aubrey
Plaza she plays Lenny one of his friends who
sort of this recovering alcoholic, that's
also stuck in the institution tries to help
them out day-to-day, but you can kind of see
how the series is mostly about him questioning
what reality is in the comics his codename
Legion actually refers to the Legion of personalities
that he contains inside of them.
So he himself is like this Legion of abilities
you superpowerful buddy just bat shit crazy
to think of him as the Walter White of comic
book characters and they did say that they
had their run of the X-Men universe basically
said there's like in a different multi-verse,
so that they can explain how he's capable
of being Professor X's child, but James McAvoy
is playing in the movies right now.
So it's much younger.
So there are any issues with the timeline
you have to imagine that Patrick Stewart's
Professor X that would fit a little bit better
with the timeline.
So there a lot of X-Men characters out there
they tease that the world knows about mutants,
so they're probably going to be a couple evil
organizations like the hellfire club with
their eyes on them along with the US government.
So in the comics a lot of the fun of this
is him trying to control his more evil personalities
member each one of his personalities is very
very powerful, but some of them are really
bad so at any given time you have the good
ones that are at war with the bad ones all
within him.
So this was their billing the series is the
psychological drama with a lot of X-Men action,
and it the series itself doesn't start till
February 8.
So it's going to be a Wednesday night show
probably 9 PM of the videos I do for it won't
post till Thursday but I feel like this should
be pretty solid for those you that are looking
for like a really hard-core X-Men series but
everybody saying that is going to be really
solid is made by the same person that made
Fargo which is winning all those crazy words,
so the Marvel people of been hyping it up
is this crazy cable show with all this awesome
stuff that they would never be able to do
on network like with agents of shield with
the probably do is drop a couple more trailers
before premier.
So I'll do videos for that.
Just to remind people that it's coming but
I feel like it will fit in the scheduling
nicely because legends of tomorrow which used
to be a Thursday show is now Tuesday show
so my schedule change the little bit.
So now Thursday's a little more open so give
me all your questions about Legion like what
you guys most excited about.
If you've never read.
The Legion character he's relatively smaller
character even though he's one of the bigger,
more powerful ones he showed up during avengers
X-Men axes just like so powerful that it is
harder to write characters like that because
it's hard to find obstacles for them but he
himself is his own obstacle just because of
his personalities their war with each other.
So I was really excited for this to get bat
shit crazy.
So you're looking for really intent show to
fill the void that Westworld game of thrones
Breaking Bad though shows have left in this
is it an election to fill the gap before the
Marvel Netflix series start to because those
on startup till March.
So there's gonna be a whole lot of really
awesome Marvel TV happening this spring DC
TV is great Marvel TV is just getting started
in the biggest thing is that there's a new
Wolverine trailer that's dropping this Thursday
so course I'll do a video for it because the
movie is coming out in a little over a month,
it's probably a little more story base will
learn more about what the actual story of
Logan is is sort of like a post-apocalyptic
story where mutant kind is died off and he's
hiding out on the Mexican border with Professor
X when the Laura X 23 character comes running
to them seeking shelter from what seems like
the reverse that seems like this evil group
of people but I'll talk about that when I
post that Logan trailer later this week.
Congratulations to the new Deadpool giveaway
winner Brussels sprouts please private message
me on the back and my channel so I can get
your contact details.
It was a new round that started in this video
just announce the winner the next time I post
a Deadpool or Legion video while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here to
learn all about what's going on with Deadpool
to the other X-Men movies and you can click
here to rewatch the trailer.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!